Boeing an Airbus two Aviation Giants
locked in a deep years-long battle to
secure Airlines orders for their
aircraft and into air shows like this
one in Paris that we often see
announcements of huge orders for
aircraft for both plane makers this year
was no exception with over 1 000 firm
orders for commercial aircraft now the
quantity and type of planes ordered can
actually help paint a picture about the
health of the aviation sector and the
strength of the duopoly between Boeing
and Airbus so what does this mean for
the future of flying let's find out
okay so first what planes have been
ordered in the run-up to the show this
year we saw huge orders from Indian
airline Air India for both Boeing and
Airbus planes shortly after came in
order for Boeing Aircraft from two Saudi
Airlines including a new Airline called
riyader then came a 40 billion order
from Ryanair for up to 300 new Boeing
737 Max Jets but those orders were
nothing compared to the mammoth order of
500 of airbus's A320 planes from another
Indian airline Indigo the largest in
aviation history no one has ever ordered
an order of this magnitude the large
volume of orders has led some in the
industry to believe that Aviation might
be able to withstand a recession to find
out why I sat down with wsj Aviation
reporter Andrew tangle orders are still
coming in thick and fast does does that
make Aviation
Recession Proof it certainly seems that
way we talked to the Airbus CEO Jim Fury
and he didn't see any slowdown in the
aviation sector I mean in terms of a
window into the economy around the world
air travel seems to be indicating a
stable strong growth and high demand
positive the reason for that growth is a
surge in post-pandemic travel which has
left Airlines scrambling for new planes
which is why we're seeing over 1 000
orders but while that may seem like a
lot of aircraft some of the planes
ordered may never actually be built
there's a history of big headline
grabbing orders being announced at air
shows only years later to be paired down
or reshuffled see right now
Honda airlines are clamoring for new
planes Boeing and Airbus are both
struggling to get them off the
production line they have the supply
problems they have their regulatory
issues they can't make planes fast
enough the weight for some Boeing and
Airbus aircraft is currently around six
years or even longer and that means that
when it comes to some Airlines orders
they're essentially buying a place in
line to get their aircraft and they're
doing it in very big ways with big
numbers of aircraft that they're
ordering But whichever way you look at
it Airbus walks away from the show with
more orders than Boeing so what does the
imbalance in orders mean for the
long-term rivalry between the two well
while Airbus is leading in the single
hour market with the vast bulk aboarders
at the show going to its A320 family of
planes when it comes to the wide body
Market those planes with twin aisles and
a long range the Airbus CEO acknowledged
that while they'll be ahead for quite
some time in the nearby Market the
competition is very fierce in the white
buddy realm but for either play maker to
sustain a lead over the other they'll
need to get planes off the production
line and into the hands of customers and
with both companies experiencing supply
chain Styles competition between the two
is expected to remain strong
[Music]